superhero movies are chock-full of high
flying action shocking moments and
lately plenty of humor but for all the
jokes that actually make it into the
final cut there are plenty more that
remain on the cutting room floor
thankfully there's the blooper reel the
time-honored tradition of capturing
those moments when actors goof off or
screw up from comic book references to
slick dance moves here are bloopers that
will make you love superhero movies even
more blooper cents tingling with
spiderman homecoming Tom Holland gave
audiences the third live action
spider-man franchise in 15 years
considering how familiar audiences were
with the character the filmmakers wisely
veered away from dwelling on the web
heads origins story still that didn't
stop Holland from putting a reference in
the blooper reel when Peter Parker
attempts to tell a teacher why he can't
commit any more time to a school
activity because of his involvement with
Tony Stark
Holland makes a clever callback to one
of the most famous lines in spider-man
history I got a lot of responsibility
with it it's great power with great
power comes great comic book knowledge
super movies need super glue Black
Panther stars chadwick boseman as King
T'Challa the titular Black Panther a
hero empowered by the heart-shaped herb
and a connection to the spiritual realm
the movie meanwhile was empowered by a
script that was just as much about a
fascinating villain Michael B Jordan
Zarek kill manga I want the prom still
regardless of how deep the characters
are action movies need stuff to get
blown up in one scene it's up to kill
monger to attach some explosives to a
building but the blooper reel reveals
that it definitely took a few tries
[Music]
you think Marvel could afford better
prop glue strange things are afoot
Doctor Strange is one of the strangest
Marvel Comics properties and effectively
bringing the character to the screen
required the involvement of a very
serious actor Benedict Cumberbatch ended
up being exactly what the doctor ordered
so to speak and he brings real gravitas
to dr. Stephen strange a guy who can use
magic and tap into the powers of
mystical entities in his fight against
evil dr. strange
Oh using your made-up names then I am
spider-man still despite the importance
of the actor the importance of the
character and the importance of his
mission sometimes all Cumberbatch can do
is just dance after seeing that we kind
of wish some of these sweet dance moves
had made it into the film Thor meets
Fleur Thor Ragnarok the third entry in
the MCU film franchise about Chris
Hemsworth's titular Norse deity mixed up
the formula a little bit under the
direction of Taika Waititi the movie is
more of a comedy about superheroes than
a straightforward superhero movie but if
I'm being honest when it comes to
fighting beings he is very powerful
useful yeah banners powerful and useful
to know still for all the jokes and
physical comedy that made it into the
actual movie there were plenty that were
relegated to the gag reel while trying
to get out the line a wise King never
seeks power Hemsworth can't walk and
talk at the same time and get stymied by
an errant step wise King Aerys it seems
like the god of thunder isn't the god of
descending staircases stormy
relationship while filming a scene for
x-men Days of Future past
Halle Berry and Hugh Jackman were
supposed to exchange some soft words and
a tender goodbye kiss this
I'm the only one who's gonna remember
any of this right okay now Barry's
obviously been waiting for this moment
for a really long time see you later
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]